[Music]
welcome everybody to just kidding news
and today's article is about how Airline
an airline a very very budget economy
Airline apparently Frontier
Spirit a new one launches new
flights with no middle seats y'all oh
that's sick do you mean wait wait wait
wait how that
budget what does that mean so
everybody's guaranteed a window or an
aisle seat no matter what okay okay okay
and and even though this is an economy
plane okay they also will give you a
complimentary beverage in or snack and
the beverage includes we want pretzel we
want brought that back do they recline
though because some of them don't even
reclin and you're sitting like this the
whole time but I don't even want how
they made planes like that where you're
just like this yeah like how can I sit
forward for [__] 3 hours like this
favorite actor Denzel to this article
would say okay all right okay all right
let's go let's go all right what's the
name of the airline can't do that that's
good right okay all right good
impression what's the name of the
airline proud of it uh this is Canada's
Porter Airline
Canada coming here where am I going to
go Montreal to C Alta St across North
America and Canada including New York
Miami Boston Ontario and Quebec and
recently announced new routes to Los
Angeles and San
Francisco all right okay okay okay all
right all right okay Steve's is better
though for some I swear to God my faite
airplane inside got smaller and then the
leg room got smaller and it feels like
my face is like right there to the back
of the someone else's seat yeah it got
effed up man they thought like the free
market you know cuz it used to be like
funded and regulated a little bit more
oh they did yeah I forgot what the deal
was it wasn't that long ago but now each
Airlines you think like capitalism would
win and they would try to like make it
more luxurious maybe one would bring a
meal back or you know like you all were
probably kids and flu and you got meals
they don't do that [__] anywhere now
it's just getting worse and worse and
worse though like literally there's not
a single like luxury airline in America
dude I'm going from Vegas to LA make
this make sense I'm going Vegas La we
take off as soon
as the captain says you can move around
or whatever the person in front of me
[__] reclines hits my nose and [__]
right and I'm like you can't even sleep
on this flight it's 25 minutes dude like
from the time they say it's okay to do
that [__] what are you doing well and
the recline is literally
this yeah yeah it is and so it goes from
here to here it does hit you in the
[__] that's what it feels like to you
but when you're back here I'm like and
you're tall too all my shit's like oh my
god what the [__] there's no room to
start with but the front guy's not my
point is that he's not even getting
comfortable so why even do it I don't
even do it cuz it's not even comfortable
just [__] with me get low back paint
he is do it's Vengeance yeah it's
Vengeance you need some lumbar support
on the things doubles are huge W that's
pretty cool actually that looks sweet I
heard very how is that a budget
airlin
dude they could make money like that huh
you know what though if plane if the
airline were truly budget and the prices
reflected that I'd be okay with it like
Spirit they don't [__] around their [__]
sucks but it's $20 one way kind of bro
but then they're grabbing you on 80
bucks for a bag $20 I don't add none of
that [__] I know but you know what I
mean like it's not actually that much
cheaper the you know how they trick you
the uh the airlines they they say oh
that is only personal items allowed and
then on a carry-on they have a picture
of a backpack so all these poor souls
think oh I need to pay another $25 for
my backpack [__] [__] that's a
personal item I heard they're working on
an airplane that's like a standing room
how go Google that real quick swear so
you stand for 45 minutes I don't know
but I heard that stupid it's cheaper
technically cuz Spirit they like 60
bucks or whatever for a bag you can ship
yourself [__] that's true that's true or
buy but you go to Ross by hold ultra low
cost Airline introduces standing room
only airplanes with no seats to increase
capacity so we're just going to get low
shittier options now yeah that's what
the rather than you would think it would
go the other way like why isn't one of
the Americans like step up a little bit
I'll pay 50 bucks more give me a meal
give me some Breathing Room give me a
Wi-Fi that [__] works you know what's
kind of crazy the seats are getting
smaller and people are getting bigger
too I was looking at like on just an
American thing last flight just even
chicks alone that are over 250 lbs are a
lot yeah a lot did you know that the
average American woman is 170 lb but
they're 53 and I not even even on the
lighter end what there's a lot of
there's a lot of just seditary people
yeah and like I'm in Fitness with Mike
and Nick I can like estimate how much
people weigh like pretty quickly those B
people 250 they don't look that comfy in
the in the chairs we should have
treadmills instead of standing room low
key if you're 5' 3 why do you need a
date a 6ot guy so bad yeah isn't that
like the new thing really I got they got
to be they got to be able to carry you
all girls like tall guys are awesome
isn't every guy who's like above 53 a
tall guy to you prob hey just having
your back thank you bro short kings are
kind of a thing though too there's a
weird like fetish I think going on I
think guys hope that that's no like
there's yeah it might be Twitter memes
there might be meeme in our asses yeah
probably done by short guys not me bro
I've never been denied because of my
height I think it's your ungodly AA been
Deni service because of my huh what what
would you
be no I never heard or even if it was
true I never heard oh you're too short
for me oh I see I see cuz I I I don't
know I date girls that are tall I
thought it was hilarious to date a girl
I think the tallest girl that I I dated
was like 61 62 for real tall climb that
one how tall 5'11 really I thought she's
like 6'1 she looks tall like really
really tall she but with shoes she's
probably six yeah oh with like heels
then she's like 6'3 all of she puts her
elbow on top of my head I don't like
that and she leans on me I don't like
that I don't like when she picks up my
legs and then [__] wraps around my
waist that's not fun oh have you seen
Amazonian woman porn have you seen that
some link oh it's good link Joe showed
us yeah it's a chick picking up a dude
and sucking his dick oh yeah yeah she
picks him up over her head yeah she goes
like this
dick yep I bet that's kind of cool but
also a little emasculating a lot of bit
probably behind those do yeah who gives
a [__] that's a fun time emasculate me
you know boy yeah yeah but if you get
just tossed around that's a little
emasculating yeah getting tossed around
you guys have never been tossed around
I've been tossed
around talking about you never been
manhandled before dude are you right
dude you're calling us out on our Bluff
okay we don't know don't know what it's
like chck Judo or something no I'm just
saying like you ever just get manhandled
by a person before yeah no I'm not a
Jiu-Jitsu artist don't touch me dude no
but like Judo people just toss you
that's yeah you can pick me up and TOS
me across the room if you want to like a
baby let him do it I'll do it right now
dude can you do it can you hold them by
chest like this I'll put five bucks on
it right now do it just pick me up like
this check are they
in what about his hand do I got to sign
NDA
Li we have a
helmet he's heavier than I thought how
much can you toss I could probably toss
100 120 lb what do you 168 yeah that's
heavy 120 I could probably eat across
the room hey where the same weight now
cuz I lost weight dude this this guy
actually piced that was kind of scary
dude we'll throw can through the wall oh
my God talking you want to can toss hey
can we thr get your ass over here he
said he could eat him going to go
through the throw you Mike can he throw
you on a couch it fails nice it wasn't
that bad yeah all right let's see if you
could push press his head into the
ceiling I could probably uh uh Save the
Last Dance or whatever the [__] that
I'll put you up there watch your head
watch your head though oh [__] yeah dude
dude has anyone ever done that to you
[__] e him no no one's done that to no
one's ever done that to you my back po
you just my back how did that feel it
was it was fun it was right you feel
more like a man or less like a man I
felt like my dad just threw me in the
pool right now am I the only one that's
horny in here all of a sudden I'm a
little hor I don't like that you make
did you imagine holding can up like that
and sucking his dick because that's what
Amazonian women thought of that no I
think that's the eighth video today that
Joe brought that in
there yeah I never thought of that these
are yours no no they're not you just
make them look better than me and I wear
mic if you want to be manhandled for a
small looks like he's the disguise nose
and the sunglasses SCH dude just my
stash
just that's on the money hey that's on
the
money it doesn't even look like AI it
looks like the real thing thing on dude
that's the real deal that's pretty sweet
what the [__] were we talking about
[Music]
a